be an outstanding president requires
Great mental acuity and physical stamina
and strength if you don't have these
qualities or traits it is likely that
you will not succeed and you will
disappoint
the entire world let alone our own
country and that's what happened under
Trump interestingly enough this is like
a very accurate diagnosis of exactly
what happened Trump couldn't do it and
everybody was indeed disappointed we
need to make America great again
take a competency test let's see whether
or not these people that are running for
office are competent
I took the test
two years ago and I aced it but I'd love
to take it again because I think I'd
even do better
she aced it but he would do better he
would get like X it's like getting a 4.4
GPA buddy running for president
we're 350 million people are relying on
you they're relying on your brain
they're relying on your competence